hey everyone welcome to this video on
the full course for cryptography
in this course we will learn everything
there is to know about cryptography and
how it helps keep our data secure on the
internet and in local storage
with encryption and decryption forming
the heart of this lesson cryptography
has become the backbone of modern
internet security
from secure website browsing to
exchanging messages on whatsapp
cryptography has its roots planted
firmly among multiple avenues all of
which will be covered in this video
so strap up and get ready for a
comprehensive course on cryptography
that can be completed in just under 3
hours
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered today
we start our lesson by understanding the
basic need for cryptography and why it
has become an integral part of our daily
lives
moving on we learn how cryptography
works its worldwide applications and its
historical significance as far as
securing data is concerned
next we know about the different ways to
employ cryptography such as symmetric
encryption
asymmetric encryption and hashing
once the basic concepts are clearly
understood we can move on to more
complex topics such as the individual
encryption and decryption algorithms
used in cryptography
the first one being the data encryption
standard or the des algorithm
next we learn about the advanced
encryption standard that is the aes
algorithm
digital signature or the dsa algorithm
and the reverse shameer edelman
algorithm also known as the rsa
encryption algorithm
we then take a look at two hashing
algorithms specifically the messaging
digest 5 or the md5 hash algorithm
and the secure hash algorithm family
also known as the sha hash algorithm
once we understand the algorithms at
play we can learn about some unique
applications of cryptography like the
secure socket layer handshake or the ssl
handshake which helps keep our web
browsers safe against malicious attacks
similarly we learn about the
diffie-hellman key exchange which was a
revolutionary protocol that enabled the
exchange of cryptographic keys over an
insecure channel finally we go through
some popular interview questions that
candidates go through when applying for
a position that deals with cryptography
or just cyber security in general
but before we start our lesson make sure
you are subscribed to the simply learn
youtube channel and the bell icon is
enabled so that you never miss an update
from us
so here's a story to help you understand
cryptography
meet ann
ann wanted to look for a decent discount
on the latest iphone she started
searching on the internet and found a
rather shady website that offered a 50
discount on the first purchase
once ann submitted her payment details a
huge chunk of money was withdrawn from a
bank account just moments after
devastated and quickly realized she had
failed to notice that the website was a
http web page instead of an https one
the payment information submitted was
not encrypted and it was visible to
anyone keeping an eye including the
website owner and hackers had she used a
reputed website which has encrypted
transactions and employees cryptography
our iphone enthusiasts could have
avoided this particular incident this is
why it's never recommended to visit
unknown websites or share any personal
information on them
now that we understand why cryptography
is so important let's now understand
what cryptography is
cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the secure storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties
encryption is the primary route for
employing cryptography by adding certain
algorithms to jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography
for example when simply learn is jumbled
up or changed in any format not many
people can guess the original word by
looking at the encrypted text
the only ones who can are the people who
know how to decrypt the coded word
thereby reversing the process of
encryption
any data pre-encryption is called plain
text or clear text
to encrypt the message we use certain
algorithms that serve a single purpose
of scrambling the data to make them
unreadable without the necessary tools
these algorithms are called ciphers
they are a set of detailed steps to be
carried out one after the other to make
sure the data becomes as unreadable as
possible until it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
ciphertext and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content
wonder what else we would lose if not
for cryptography
any website where you have an account
can read your passwords important emails
can be intercepted and their contents
can be read without encryption during
the transit
more than 65 billion messages are sent
on whatsapp every day all of which are
secured thanks to end to end encryption
there is a huge market opening up for
cryptocurrency which is possible due to
blockchain technology that uses
encryption algorithms and hashing
functions to ensure that the data is
secure
cryptography has been in practice for
centuries
julius caesar used a substitution shift
to move alphabets a certain number of
spaces beyond their place in the
alphabet table
a spy can't decipher the original
message at first glance for example if
he wanted to pass confidential
information to his armies and decides to
use the substitution shift of plus 2 a
becomes c b becomes d and so on the word
attack when passed through a
substitution shift of plus 3 becomes d w
d e f n
this cipher has been appropriately named
the caesar cipher which is one of the
most widely used algorithms
the enigma is probably the most famous
cryptographic cipher device used in
ancient history
it was used by the nazi german armies in
the world wars they were used to protect
confidential political
military and administrative information
and it consisted of three or more rotors
that scrambled the original message
depending on the machine state at that
time the decryption is similar but it
needs both machines to stay in the same
state before passing the cipher text so
that we receive the same plain text
message
there are two types of encryption in
cryptography
symmetric key cryptography
and asymmetric key cryptography
both of these categories have their pros
and cons and differ only by the
implementation
today we are going to focus exclusively
on symmetry key cryptography
let us have a look at its applications
in order to understand its importance
better
this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
where personally identifiable
information needs to be encrypted
with so many aspects of banking moving
on to the internet having a reliable
safety net is crucial
symmetric cryptography helps in
detecting bank fraud and boosts the
security index of these payment gateways
in general
they are also helpful in protecting data
that is not in transit and dress on
servers and data centers
these centers house a massive amount of
data that needs to be encrypted with a
fast and efficient algorithm so that
when the data needs to be recalled by
the respective service there is the
assurance of minor to no delay
while browsing the internet we need
symmetric encryption to browse secure
https websites so that we get an
all-around protection
it plays a significant role in verifying
website server authenticity exchanging
the necessary encryption keys required
and generating a session using those
keys to ensure maximum security
this helps us in preventing the rather
insecure hdp website format
so let us understand how symmetric key
cryptography works first before moving
on to the specific algorithms
symmetric key cryptography relies on a
single key for the encryption and
decryption of information
both the sender and receiver of the
message need to have a pre-shared secret
key that they will use to convert the
plain text into ciphertext and vice
versa
as you can see in the image the key used
for encryption is the same key needed
for decrypting the message at the other
end the secret key shouldn't be sent
along with the cipher text to the
receiver because that would defeat the
entire purpose of using cryptography key
exchange can be done beforehand using
other algorithms like the diffie-hellman
key exchange protocol for example
for example if paul wants to send a
simple message to jane they need to have
a single encryption key that both of
them must keep secret to prevent
snooping on by malicious actors
it can be generated by either one of
them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message i am ready is
converted into ciphertext using a
specific substitution cipher by paul in
that case jane must also be aware of the
substitution shift to decrypt the
ciphertext once it reaches her
irrespective of the scenario where
someone manages to grab the ciphertext
mid-transit to try and read the message
not having the secret key renders
everyone helpless looking to snoop in
the symmetric key algorithms like the
data encryption standard have been in
use since the 1970s while the popular
ones like the ees have become the
industry standard today
with the entire architecture of
symmetric cryptography depending on the
single key being used you can understand
why it's of paramount importance to keep
it secret on all occasions
the side effect of having a single key
for the encryption and decryption is it
becomes a single point of failure anyone
who gets their hand on it can read all
the encrypted messages and do so mainly
without the knowledge of the sender and
the receiver so it is the priority to
keep the encryption and encryption key
private at all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages to either
the sender or the receiver using the
same key to encrypt the message
upon receiving the message and
decrypting it with the key it is
impossible to guess its origin
if the sender somehow transmits the
secret key along with the cipher text
anyone can intercept the package and
access the information
consequently this encryption category is
termed private key cryptography since a
big part of the data's integrity is
riding on the promise that the users can
keep the key secret this terminology
contrasts with asymmetry key
cryptography which is called public key
cryptography because it has two
different keys at play one of which is
public
provided we managed to keep the key
secret we still have to choose what kind
of ciphers we want to use to encrypt
this information in symmetric key
cryptography there are broadly two
categories of ciphers that we can employ
let us have a look
stream ciphers are the algorithms that
encode basic information one bit at a
time
it can change depending on the algorithm
being used but usually it's relies on a
single bit or byte to do the encryption
this is the relatively quicker
alternative considering the algorithm
doesn't have to deal with blocks of data
at a single time
every piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to be converted
into binary format
in stream ciphers each binary digit is
encrypted one after the other the most
popular ones are the rc4 salsa and
panama
the binary data is passed through an
encryption key which is a randomly
generated bit stream
upon passing it through we receive the
ciphertext that can be transferred to
the receiver without fear of man in the
middle attacks
the binary data can be passed through an
algorithmic function it can have either
x or operations as it is most of the
time or any other mathematical
calculations that have the singular
purpose of scrambling the data
the encryption key is generated using
the random bitstream generator and it
acts as a supplement in the algorithmic
function the output is in binary form
which is then converted into the decimal
or hexadecimal format to give our final
ciphertext
on the other hand block ciphers dissect
the raw information into chunks of data
of fixed size
the size of these blocks depend on the
exact cipher being used a 128-bit block
cipher will break the plain text into
blocks of 128 bit each and encrypt those
blocks instead of a single digit once
these blocks are encrypted individually
they are chained together to form a
final cipher text
block ciphers are much slower but they
are more tamper-proof and are used in
some of the most widely used algorithms
employed today
just like stream ciphers the original
ciphertext is converted into binary
format before beginning the process
once the conversion is complete the
blocks are passed through the encryption
algorithm along with the encryption key
this would provide us
with the encrypted blocks of binary data
once these blocks are combined we get a
final binary string
this string is then converted into
hexadecimal format to get our ciphertext
today the most popular symmetric key
algorithms like aes des and 3des are all
block cipher methodology
subsets with so many factors coming into
play there are quite a few things
symmetrically cryptography excels at
while falling short and some other
symmetric key cryptography is much
faster variant when compared to
asymmetric key cryptography there is
only one key in play unlike asymmetric
encryption and this drastically improves
calculation speed in the encryption and
decryption
similarly the performance of symmetric
encryption is much more efficient under
similar computational limitations fewer
calculations help in better memory
management for the whole system
bulk amounts of data that need to be
encrypted are very well suited for
symmetric algorithms since they are much
quicker handling large amounts of data
is simple and easy to use in servers and
data forms this helps in better latency
during data recall and fewer mixed
packets
thanks to its simple single key
structure symmetric key cryptography
algorithms are much easier to set up a
communication channel with and offer a
much more straightforward maintenance
duties once the secret key is
transmitted to both the sender and
receiver without any prior mishandling
the rest of the system aligns easily and
everyday communications becomes easy and
secure if the algorithm is applied as
per the documentation symmetric
algorithms are very robust and can
encrypt vast amounts of data with very
less overhead we took a look at
symmetric key cryptography
we used a single private key for both
the encryption and decryption of data
and it works very well in theory let's
take a look at a more realistic scenario
now
let's meet joe
joe is a journalist who needs to
communicate with ryan via long distance
messaging
due to the critical nature of the
information people are waiting for any
message to leave joe's house so that
they can intercept it
now joe can easily use symmetric
cryptography to send the encrypted data
so that even if someone intercepts the
message they cannot understand what it
says
but here's the tricky part
how will joe send the required
decryption key to ryan
the sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key so that they can exchange
messages otherwise ryan cannot decrypt
the information even when he receives
the cipher text
if someone intercepts the key while
transmitting it there is no use in
employing cryptography since the third
party can now decode all the information
easily
key sharing is a risk that will always
exist when symmetric key cryptography is
being used
thankfully asymmetric key encryption has
managed to fix this problem
let's understand what asymmetric key
cryptography is
asymmetric encryption uses a double
layer of protection
there are two different keys at play
here a private key and a public key
a public key is used to encrypt the
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the data post
transit
these pair of keys must belong to the
receiver of the message
the public keys can be shared via
messaging blog posts or key servers and
there are no restrictions
as you can see in the image the two keys
are working in the system
the sender first encrypts the message
using the receiver's private key after
which we receive the ciphertext the
ciphertext is then transmitted to the
receiver without any other key on
getting the ciphertext the receiver uses
his private key to decrypt it and get
the plain text back
there has been no requirement of any key
exchange throughout this process
therefore solving the most glaring flaw
faced in symmetric key cryptography
the public key known to everyone cannot
be used to decrypt the message and the
private key which can decrypt the
message need not be shared with anyone
the sender and receiver can exchange
personal data using the same set of keys
as often as possible
to understand this better
take the analogy of your mailbox
anyone who wants to send you a letter
has access to the box and can easily
share information with you
in a way you can say the mailbox is
publicly available to all but only you
have access to the key that can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it
this is how the private key comes to
play
no one can intercept the message and
read its contents since it's encrypted
once the receiver gets its contents he
can use his private key to decrypt the
information
both the public key and the private key
are generated so they are interlinked
and you cannot substitute other private
keys to decrypt the data
in another example if alice wants to
send a message to bob
let's say it reads call me today she
must use bob's public key while
encrypting the message
upon receiving the cipher message bob
can proceed to use his private key in
order to decrypt the message and hence
complete securities attained during
transmission without any need for
sharing the key
since this type of encryption is highly
secure it has many uses in areas that
require high confidentiality
it is used to manage digital signature
so there is valid proof of a document's
authenticity
with so many aspects of business
transitioning to the digital sphere
critical documents need to be verified
before being considered authentic and
acted upon
thanks to asymmetric cryptography
senders can now sign documents with
their private keys
anyone who needs to verify the
authenticity of such signatures can use
the sender's public key to decrypt the
signature
since the public and the private keys
are linked to each other mathematically
it's impossible to repeat this
verification with duplicate keys
document encryption has been made very
simple by today's standards but the
background implementation follows the
stimulus approach
in blockchain architecture asymmetry key
cryptography is used to authorize
transactions and maintain the system
thanks to its two key structures changes
are reflected across the blockchain's
peer-to-peer network only if it is
approved from both ends along with
asymmetric key cryptography's
tamper-proof architecture its
non-repudiation characteristic also
helps in keeping the network stable
we can also use asymmetric key
cryptography combined with symmetrical
cryptography to monitor ssl or tls
encrypted browsering sessions to make
sure nobody can steal our personal
information when accessing banking
websites or the internet in general
it plays a significant role in verifying
website server authenticity exchanging
the necessary encryption keys required
and generating a session using those
keys to ensure maximum security instead
of the rather insecure http website
format
security parameters differ on a session
by session basis so the verification
process is consistent and utterly
essential to modern data security
another great use of the asymmetric key
cryptography structure is transmitting
keys for symmetric key cryptography with
the most significant difficulty in
symmetric encryption being key exchange
asymmetric keys can help clear the
shortcoming the original message is
first encrypted using a symmetric key
the key used for encrypting the data is
then converted into the cipher text
using the receiver's public key now we
have two cipher text to transmit to the
receiver
on receiving both of them the receiver
uses his private key to decrypt the
symmetry key he can then use it to
decrypt the original information on
getting the key used to encrypt the data
while this may seem more complicated
than just asymmetric cryptography alone
symmetric encryption algorithms are much
more optimized for vast amounts of data
on some occasions
encrypting the key using asymmetric
algorithms will definitely be more
memory efficient and secure
you might remember us discussing why
symmetric encryption was called private
key cryptography
let us understand why asymmetric falls
under the public key cryptography
we have two keys at our disposal
the encryption key is available to
everyone
the decryption key is supposed to be
private
unlike symmetric key cryptography there
is no need to share anything privately
to have an encrypted messaging system to
put that into perspective we share an
email address with anyone looking to
communicate with us it is supposed to be
public by design so that our email login
credentials are private and they help in
preventing any data mishandling
since there is nothing hidden from the
world if they want to send us any
encrypted information this category is
called the public key cryptography with
so many variables in play there must be
some advantages that give asymmetrically
cryptography an edge over the
traditional symmetric encryption
methodologies
let's go through some of them
there is no need for any reliable key
sharing channel in asymmetric encryption
it was an added risk in private key
cryptography that has been completely
eliminated in public key architecture
the key which is made public cannot
recruit any confidential information and
the only key that can decrypt doesn't
need to be shared publicly under any
circumstance we have much more extensive
key lengths in rsa encryption and other
asymmetric algorithms like 2048 bits key
and 4096 bit keys
larger keys are much harder to break
into via brute force and are much more
secure
asymmetric key cryptography can use as a
proof of authenticity since only the
rightful owner of the keys can generate
the messages to be decrypted by the
private key the situation can also be
reversed encryption is done using a
private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the owner
it also has a tamper protection feature
where the message cannot be intercepted
and changed without invalidating the
private key used to encrypt the data
consequently the public key cannot
decrypt the message and it is easy to
realize the information is not 100
legitimate when and where the case
requires before getting too deep into
the topic let's get a brief overview of
how hashing works
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of information or data beyond
recognition
we can achieve this by using hash
functions which are essentially
algorithms that perform mathematical
operations on the main plain text
the value generated after passing the
plaintext information through the hash
function is called the hash value digest
or in general just the hash of the
original data
while this may sound similar to
encryption the major difference is
hashes are meant to be irreversible no
decryption key can convert a digest back
to its original value however a few
hashing algorithms have been broken due
to the increase in computational
complexity of today's new generation
computers and processors
there are new algorithms that stand the
test of time and are still in news among
multiple areas for password storage
identity verification etc
like we discussed earlier websites use
hashing to store the user's passwords
so how do they make use of these hash
passwords
when a user signs up to create a new
account the password is then run through
the hash function and the resulting hash
value is stored on the servers
so the next time a user comes to login
to the account the password he enters is
passed to the same hash function and
compared to the hash stored on the main
server
if the newly calculated hash is the same
as the one stored on the website server
the password must have been correct
because according to hash functions
terminology same inputs will always
provide the same outputs
if the hashes do not match then the
password entered during login is not the
same as the password entered during the
signup hence the login will be denied
this way no plain text passwords get
stored preventing both the owner from
snooping on user data and protecting
users privacy in the unfortunate event
of a data breach or a hack
apart from password storage hashing can
also be used to perform integrity checks
when a file is uploaded on the internet
the files hash value is generated and it
is uploaded along with the original
information
when a new user downloads the file he
can calculate the digest of the
downloaded file using the same hash
function
when the hash values are compared if
they match then file integrity has been
maintained and there has been no data
corruption
since so much important information is
being passed on to the hash function we
need to understand how they work
a hash function is a set of mathematical
calculations operated on two blocks of
data
the main input is broken down into two
blocks of similar size
the block size is dependent on the
algorithm that is being used
hash functions are designed to be one
way they shouldn't be reversible at
least by design
some algorithms like the previously
mentioned md5 have been compromised but
most secure algorithms are being used
today like the sha family of algorithms
the digest size is also dependent on the
respective algorithm being used
md5 has a digest of 128 bits while
srg-256 has a digest of 256 bits
this digest must always be the same for
the same input irrespective of how many
times the calculations are carried out
this is a very crucial feature since
comparing the hash value is the only way
to check if the data is untouched as the
functions are not reversible
there are certain requirements of a hash
function that need to be met before they
are accepted
while some of them are easy to guess
others are placed in order to preserve
security in the long run
the hash function must be quick enough
to encrypt large amounts of data at a
relatively fast pace
but it also shouldn't be very fast
running the algorithm on all cylinders
makes the functions easy to boot force
and a security liability
there must be a balance to allow the
hash function to handle large amounts of
data and not make it ridiculously easy
to brute force by running through all
the possible combinations
the hash function must be dependent on
each bit of the input
the input can be text audio video or any
other file extension
if a single character is being changed
it doesn't matter how small that
character may be the entire digest must
have a distinctly different hash value
this is essential to create unique
digest for every password that is being
stored
but what if two different users are
using the same password
since the hash function is the same for
all users both the digest will be the
same
this is called a hash collision
you may think this must be a rare
occasion where two users have exactly
the same password but that is not the
case
we have techniques like salting that can
be used to reduce these hash collisions
as we will discuss later in this video
you would be shocked to see the most
used passwords of 2020. all of these
passwords are laughably insecure and
since many people use the same passwords
repeatedly on different websites hash
collisions risks are more common than
one would expect
let's say the hash functions find two
users having the same password
how can they store both the hashes
without messing up the original data
this is where salting and peppering come
to play
salting is the process of adding a
random keyword to the end of the input
before it is passed on to the hash
function
this random keyword is unique for each
user on the system and it is called the
solved value or just the sort
so even if two passwords are exactly the
same the solved value will differ and so
will their digest
there is a small problem in this process
though
since the salt is unique for each user
they need to be stored in the database
along with the passwords and sometimes
even in plain text to speed up the
process of continuous verification if
the server is hacked then the hashes
will need to be brute forced which takes
a lot of time but if they receive the
salts as well the entire process becomes
very fast
this is something that peppering aims to
solve
peppering is the process of adding a
random string of data to the input
before passing them to the hash function
but this time the random string is not
unique for each user it is supposed to
be common for all users in the database
and the extra bit added is called the
pepper in this case
the pepper isn't stored on the servers
it is mostly hard coded onto the website
source code since it's going to be the
same for all credentials
this way even if the servers get hacked
they will not have the right pepper
needed to crack into all the passwords
many websites use a combination of
salting and preparing to solve the
problem of hash collision and bolster
security
since brute force takes such a long time
many hackers avoid taking the effort the
returns are mostly not worth it and the
possible combinations of using both
salting and peppery is humongous in
today's world the most widely used
symmetric encryption algorithm is aes
256 that stands for advanced encryption
standard which has a key size of 256 bit
with 128 bit and 196 bit key sizes also
being available
other primitive algorithms like the data
encryption standard that is the des the
triple data encryption standard 3des and
blowfish have all fallen out of favor
due to the rise of aes
the es algorithm stands for data
encryption standard
it is a symmetric key cipher that is
used to encrypt and re-kept information
and are blocked by block manner
each block is encrypted individually and
they are later chained together to form
our final cipher text which is then sent
to a receiver des takes the original
unaltered piece of data called the plain
text in a 64-bit block and it is
converted into an encrypted text that is
called the ciphertext
it uses 48-bit keys during the
encryption process and follows a
specific structure called the fiscal
cipher structure during the entire
process
it is a symmetric key algorithm which
means des can reuse the keys used in the
encryption format to decrypt the cipher
text back to the original plain text
once the 64-bit blocks are encrypted
they can be combined together before
being transmitted
let's take a look at the origin and the
reason the es was founded
das is based on a fiscal block cipher
called lucifer developed in 1971 by ibm
cryptography researcher host vista
des uses 16 rounds of the swisstal
structure using a different key for each
round
it also utilizes a random function with
two inputs and provides a single output
variable
the es became the organization's
approved encryption standard in november
1976 and was later reaffirmed as our
standard in 1983 1988 and finally in
1999
but eventually the es was cracked and it
was no longer considered a secure
solution for all official routes of
communication
consequently triple ds was developed
triple res is a symmetric key block
cipher that uses a double ds cipher
encrypt with the first key delete
encryption with the second key and
encrypt again with a third key there is
also a variation of the two keys where
the first and second key are duplicate
of each other but triple ds was
ultimately deemed too slow for the
growing need for fast communication
channels and people eventually fell back
to using ds for encrypting messages
in order to search for a better
alternative a public wide competition
was organized and helped cryptographers
develop their own algorithm as a
proposal for the next global standard
this is where the rindyle algorithm came
into play and was later credited to be
the next advanced encryption standard
for a long time des was the standard for
data encryption for data security
its rule ended in 2002 when finally the
advanced encryption standard replaced
des as an acceptable standard following
a public competition for a place
to understand the structure of a fistal
cipher we can use the following image as
a reference
the block being encrypted is divided
into two parts one of which is being
passed on to the function while the
other part is xored with the function's
output
the function also uses the encryption
key that differs for each individual
round
this keeps going on until the last step
until where the right hand side and the
left hand side are being swapped here we
receive our final ciphertext
for the decryption process the entire
procedure is reversed starting from the
order of the keys to the block sorting
if the entire process is repeated in a
reverse order we will eventually get
back our plain text and this simplicity
helps the speed
overall this was later detrimental to
the efficiency of the algorithm hence
the security was compromised
a fiscal block cipher is a structure
used to derive many symmetry block
ciphers such as des which as we have
discussed in our previous comment
crystal cipher proposed a structure that
implements substitution and permutation
alternately so that we can obtain cipher
text from the plain text and vice versa
this helps in reducing the redundancy of
the program and increases the complexity
to combat brute force attacks
the pistol cipher is actually based on
the shannon structure that was proposed
in 1945 the fistel cipher is the
structure suggested by horst feistel
which was considered to be a backbone
while developing many symmetric block
ciphers
the shannon structure highlights the
implementation of alternate confusion
and diffusion
and like we already discussed the fiscal
cipher structure can be completely
reversed depending on the data however
we must consider the fact that to
decrypt the information by reversing the
physical structure we will need the
exact polynomial functions and the key
orders
to understand how the blocks are being
calculated we take a plain text which is
of 64-bit and it is later divided into
two equal halves of 32-bit each
in this the right half is immediately
transferred to the next round to become
the new left half of the second row
the right hand is again passed off to a
function which uses an encryption key
that is unique to each round in the
fisted cipher
whatever the function gives off as an
output it is passed on as an xor input
with the left half of the initial plain
text
the next output will become the right
half of the second round for the plain
text
this entire process constitutes of a
single round in the fiscal cipher
taking into account what happens in a
polynomial function
we take one half of the block and pass
it through an expansion box the work of
the expansion box is to increase the
size of the half from 32-bit to 48-bit
text
this is done to make the text compatible
to a 48-bit keys we have generated
beforehand
once we pass it through the xor function
we get a 48-bit text as an output
now remember a half should be of 32-bit
so this 48-bit output is then later
passed on to a substitution box this
substitution box reduces its size from
48 bit to 32 bit output which is then
later xor with the first half of the
plain text
a block cipher is considered the safest
if the size of the block is large
but large block sizes can also slow down
encryption speed and the decryption
screen
generally the size is 64 bit
sometimes modern block ciphers like aes
have a 128 bit block size as well
the security of the block server
increases with increasing key size
but larger key sizes may also reduce the
speeds of the process
earlier 64-bit keys were considered
sufficient modern ciphers need to use
128-bit keys due to the increasing
complexity of today's computational
standards
the increasing number of rounds also
increase the security of the block
cipher
similarly they are inversely
proportional to the speed of encryption
a highly complex round function enhances
the security of the block cipher always
we must maintain a balance between the
speed and security
the symmetric block cipher is
implemented in a software application to
achieve better execution speed
there is no use of an algorithm it
cannot be implemented in a real-life
framework that can help organizations to
encrypt or decrypt the data in a timely
manner now that we understand the basics
of fiscal ciphers we can take a look at
how des manages to run through 16 rounds
of the structure and provide the cipher
text at the end
now that we understand the basics of
crystal cybers we can take a look at how
des manages to run through 16 rounds of
this structure and provide a cipher text
in simple terms ds takes the 64-bit
plaintext and converts it into a 64-bit
cipher text and since we are talking
about these symmetric algorithms the
same key is being used when it is
decrypting the data as well
we first take a 64-bit clip plain text
and we pass it to an initial permutation
function
the initial permission function has the
job of dividing the block into two
different parts so that we can perform
fiscal recycler structures on it
there are multiple rounds being procured
in the ds algorithm namely 16 rounds of
fiscal cipher structure
each of these rounds will need keys
initially we take a 56 bit cipher key
but it is a single key
we pass it on to a round key generator
which generates 16 different keys for
each single round that the fistal cipher
is being run
these keys are passed on to the rounds
as 48 bits
the size of these 48 bits case is the
reason we use the substitution and
permutation bonds in the polynomial
functions of the special ciphers
when passing through all these rounds we
reach round 16 but the final key is
passed on from the round key generator
and we get a final permutation in the
final permutation the values are swapped
and we get our final cipher text
this is the entire process of des with
16 rounds of pistol servers encompassed
in it to decrypt our cipher text back to
the plain text we just have to reverse
the process we did in the des algorithm
and reverse the key order along with the
functions this kind of simplicity is
what gave des the bonus when it comes to
speed but eventually it was detrimental
to the overall efficiency of the program
when it comes to security factors
bes have five different modes of
operation to choose from
this one of those is electronic code
book
each 64-bit block is encrypted and
decrypted independently in the
electronic code book format
we also have cipher block chaining or
the cbc method
here each 64-bit block depends on the
previous one and all of them use an
initialization vector
we have a cipher feedback block
mechanism where the preceding ciphertext
becomes the input for the encryption
algorithm
it produces a pseudo random output which
in turn is xored with the plain text
there is an output feedback method as
well which is the same as cipher
feedback except that the encryption
algorithm input is the output from the
preceding des
a counter method has a different way of
approach where each plaintext block is
xored with an encrypted counter
the counter is then incremented for each
subsequent block there are a few other
alternatives to these modes of operation
but the five mentioned above are the
most widely used in the industry and
recommended by cryptographers worldwide
let's take a look at the future of
des dominance of des ended in 2002 when
the advanced encryption standard
replaced the ds encryption algorithm as
the accepted standard it was done by
following a public competition to find a
replacement
nist officially withdrew the global
acceptance standard in may 2005 although
triple des has approved for some
sensitive government information through
2030.
nist also had to change the ds algorithm
because its key length was too short
given the increased processing power of
the new computers
encryption power is related to the size
of the queue and des found itself a
victim of ongoing technological advances
in computing
we have received a point where 56 bit
was no longer a challenge to the
computers of tracking
note that because ds is no longer the
nist federal standard does not mean that
it is no longer in use triple ds is
still used today and is still considered
a legacy encryption algorithm
in our last video we saw how the data
encryption standard also known as ds
became the global standard for
encryption and data security
eventually with so much computing power
growth the need for a stronger algorithm
was necessary to safeguard our personal
data
as solid as des was the computers of
today could easily break the encryption
with repeated attempts thereby rendering
the data security helpless
to counter this dilemma a new standard
was introduced which was termed as the
advanced encryption standard or the aes
algorithm
let's learn what is advanced encryption
standard
the aes algorithm also known as the
raindial algorithm is a symmetric block
cipher with a block size of 128 bits
it is converted into cipher text using
keys of 128 192 or 256 bits
it is implemented in software and
hardware throughout the world to encrypt
sensitive data
the national institute of standards and
technology also known as nist started
development on aes in 1997 when it was
announced the need for an alternative to
the data encryption standard the new
internet needed a replacement for des
because of its small key size
with increasing computing power it was
considered unsafe against entire key
search attacks
the triple ds was designed to overcome
this problem however it was deemed to be
too slow to be deployed in machines
worldwide
strong cases were present by the mars
rc6 serpent and the two fish algorithms
but it was the rindal encryption
algorithm also known as aes which was
eventually chosen as the standard
symmetric key encryption algorithm to be
used
its selection was formalized with the
release of federal information
processing standards publication 197 in
the november of 2001. it was approved by
the u.s secretary of commerce
now that we understand the origin of aes
let us have a look at the features that
make aes encryption algorithm unique
the aes algorithm uses a substitution
permutation or sp network
it consists of multiple rounds to
produce a ciphertext
it has a series of linked operations
including replacing inputs with specific
outputs that is substitutions and others
that involve bit shuffling which is
permutations
at the beginning of the encryption
process we only start out with a single
key which can be either a 128-bit key a
192-bit key or a 256-bit key eventually
this one key is expanded to be used in
multiple rounds throughout the
encryption and the decryption cycle
interestingly aes performs all its
calculations on byte data instead of bit
data as seen in the case of the ds
algorithm
therefore aes treats 128 bits of a clear
text block as 16 bytes
the number of rounds during the
encryption process depends on the key
size that is being used
the 128 bit key size fixes 10 rounds the
192 bit key size fixes 12 rounds and the
256 bit key holds 14 rounds
a round key is required for each of
these rounds but since only one key is
input into the algorithm the single key
needs to be expanded to get the key for
each own including the round zero
with so many mathematical calculations
going on in the background there are
bound to be a lot of steps throughout
the procedure
let's have a look at the steps followed
in aes
before we move ahead we need to
understand how data is being stored
during the process of aes encryption
everything in the process is stored in a
4 into 4 matrix format
this matrix is also known as a state
array and we'll be using these state
arrays to transmit data from one step to
another and from one round to the next
round
each round takes state arrow as input
and gives a straight array as output to
be transferred into the next round
it is a 16 byte matrix with each cell
representing one byte
with each four bytes representing a word
so every state area will have a total of
four words representing it
as we previously discussed we take a
single key and expand it to the number
of rounds that we need the key to be
used in
let's say the number of rounds are n
then the key has to be expanded to be
used with n plus 1 rounds because the
first round is the key 0 round
let's say n is the number of rounds the
key is expanded to n plus 1 rounds
it is also a state array having 4 words
in its vicinity
every key is used for a single round and
the first key is used as a round key
before any round begins
in the very beginning the plain text is
captured and passed through an xor
function with the round key as a
supplement
this key can be considered the first key
from the n plus 1 expanded set moving on
the state array resulting from the above
step is passed on to a byte substitution
process
beyond that there is a provision to
shift rows in the state arrays
later on the state array is mixed with a
constant matrix to shuffle its column in
the mix column segment
after which we add the round key for
that particular round
the last four steps mentioned are part
of every single round that the
encryption algorithm goes through
the state arrays are then passed from
one round to the next as an input
in the last round however we skip the
mix columns portion with the rest of the
process remaining unchanged
but what are these byte substitution and
row shifting processes let's find out
regarding each step in more detail
in the first step the plain text is
stored in a state array and is absorbed
with the k0 which is the first key in
the expanded key set
this step is performed only once on a
block while being repeated at the end of
each round as per iteration demands
the state array is xored with the key to
get a new state array which is then
passed off as input to the sub bytes
process
in the second stage we have byte
substitution
we leverage an xbox called as a
substitution box to randomly switch data
among each element
every single byte is converted into a
hexadecimal value having two parts
the first part denotes the row value and
the second part denotes the column value
the entire state array is passed through
the s box to create a brand new state
array which is then passed off as an
input to the row shifting process
the 16 input bytes are replaced by
looking at a fixed table given in the
design we finally get a matrix with four
rows and four columns
when it comes to row shifting each bit
in the four rows of the matrix is
shifted to the left
an entry that is a falloff is reinserted
to the right of the line the change is
done as follows
the first line is not moved in any way
the second line is shifted to a single
position to the left
the third line is shifted two positions
to the left and the fourth line is
shifted three positions to the left
the result is a new matrix that contains
the same 16 bytes but has been moved in
relation to each other to boost the
complexity of the program
in mixed columns each column of 4 bytes
is now replaced using a special
mathematical function
the function takes 4 bytes of a column
as input and outputs 4 completely new
bytes
we will get a new matrix with the same
size of 16 bytes and it should be noted
that this phase has not been done in the
last round of the iteration
when it comes to adding a round key the
16 bytes of the matrix are treated as
128 bits and the 128 bits of the round
key are exot
if it is the last round the output is
the cipher text
if you still have a few rounds remaining
the resulting 128 bits are interpreted
as 16 bytes and we start another similar
round
let's take an example to understand how
all these processes work
if our plain text is the
string 2 1 9 2 we first convert it into
a hexadecimal format as follows
we use an encryption key which is that's
my kungfu and it is converted into a
hexadecimal format as well
as per the guidelines we use a single
key which is then later expanded into n
plus 1 number of keys in which case is
supposed to be 11 keys for 10 different
rounds
in round 0 we add the round key the
plain test is xor with the k0 and we get
a state array that is passed off as an
input to the substitution by its process
when it comes to the substitution bytes
process we leverage an s box to
substitute the elements of each byte
with a completely new byte
this way the state array that we receive
is passed off as an input to the row
shifting process on the next step
when it comes to row shifting each
element is shifted a few places to the
left with the first two being shifted by
zero places second row by one place
third row by two places and the last by
three
the state array that we received from
the row shifting is passed off as an
input to mix columns
in mixed columns we multiply the
straight array with a constant matrix
after which i receive a new state array
to be passed on onto the next step
we add the name state array as an xor
with the round key of the particular
iteration
whatever state array we receive here it
becomes an output for this particular
round
now since this is the first round of the
entire encryption process the state
array that we receive is passed off as
an input to the new round
we repeat this process for 10 more
rounds and we finally receive a
ciphertext
once the final state array can be
denoted in the hexadecimal format this
becomes our final ciphertext that we can
use for transferring information from
the sender and receiver
let's take a look at the applications of
aes in this world
aes finds most use in the area of
wireless security in order to establish
a secure mode of authentication between
routers and clients
highly secure mechanisms like wpa and
wpa2 psk are extensively used in
securing wi-fi endpoints with the help
of rindel's algorithm
it also helps in ssl tls encryption that
is instrumental in encrypting our
internet browser sessions
aes works in tandem with other
asymmetric encryption algorithms to make
sure the web browser and web server are
properly configured and use encrypted
channels for communication
aes is also prevalent in general file
encryption of various formats ranging
from critical documents to the media
files
having a large key allows people to
encrypt media and decrypt data with
maximum security possible
aes is also used for processor security
in hardware appliances to prevent
machine hijacking among other things
as a direct successor to the des
algorithm there are some aspects that
aes provides an immediate advantage in
let us take a look
when it comes to key length the biggest
flaw in ds algorithm was its small
length was easily vulnerable by today's
standards aes has managed to nab up 128
192 and 256 bit key lens to bolster the
security further
the block size is also larger in aes
leaving to more complexity of the
algorithm
the number of rounds in des is fixed
irrespective of the plain text being
used in aes the number of round depends
on the key length that is being used for
the particular iteration thereby
providing more randomness and complexity
in the algorithm
the ds algorithm is considered to be
simpler than aes even though aes beats
des when it comes to relative speed of
encryption and decryption
this makes advanced encryption standard
much more streamlined to be deployed in
frameworks and systems worldwide when it
compares to the data encryption standard
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
with the decline of symmetric encryption
algorithms or private message encryption
new cypher suits came into light
the glaring issue with symmetric
algorithms was key exchange
having to pass secret keys is a risk on
its own right and that we were unable to
solve in a lot of scenarios
thankfully ds algorithm has managed to
solve this problem the use cases for
this cipher is rather niche but crucial
nonetheless
let's understand what digital signatures
are before moving on to the algorithm
the objective of digital signatures is
to authenticate and verify documents and
data
this is necessary to avoid tampering and
digital modification or forgery of any
kind during the transmission of official
documents
they work on the public key cryptography
architecture with one exception
typically an asymmetric key system
encrypts using a public key and decrypts
the private key
for digital signatures however the
reverse is true
the signature is encrypted using a
private key and is decrypted with the
public key
because the keys are inked together
decoding it with the public key verifies
that the proper private key was used to
sign the document therefore verifying
the signature's provenance
let's go through each step to understand
the procedure thoroughly
in step 1 we have m which is the
original plain text message
and it has passed on to a hash function
denoted by h
to create a digest
next it bundles the message together
with the hash digest and encrypts it
using the sender's private key
it sends the encrypted bundle to the
receiver who can decrypt it using the
sender's public key
once the message is decrypted it is
passed through the same hash function h
hash to generate a similar digest
it compares the newly generated hash
with the bundled hash value received
along with the message if they match it
verifies data integrity
in many instances they provide a layer
of validation and security messages
through non-secure channel
properly implemented a digital signature
gives the receiver reason to believe
that the message was sent by the claimed
sender
digital signatures are equivalent to
traditional handwritten signatures in
many respects but properly implemented
digital signatures are more difficult to
forge than the handwritten type
digital signature schemes in the sense
used here are cryptographically based
and must be implemented properly to be
effective
they can also provide non-repudiation
meaning that the signer cannot
successfully claim that they did not
sign a message while also claiming their
private key remains secret
further some non-repudiation schemes
offer a timestamp for the digital
signature so that even if the private
key is exposed the signature is valid
to implement the concept of digital
signature in real world we have two
primary algorithms to follow
the rsa algorithm
and the dsl algorithm but the latter is
a topic of learning today
so let's go ahead and see what the
digital signature algorithm is supposed
to do
digital signature algorithm is fips
standard which is a federal information
processing standard for digital
signatures
it was proposed in 1991 and globally
standardized in 1994 by the national
institute of standards and technology
also known as the nist
it functions on the framework of modular
exponential and discrete logarithmic
problems which are difficult to compute
as a force brute system
unlike dsa most signature types are
generated by signing message digest with
the private key of the originator
this creates a digital thumbprint of the
data
since just the message digest is signed
the signature is generally much smaller
compared to the data that was saying
as a result digital signatures impose
less load on processors at the time of
signing execution and they use small
volumes of bandwidth
dsa on the other hand does not encrypt
message digest using private key or dkip
message digest using public key
instead it uses mathematical functions
to create a digital signature consisting
of two 160 bit numbers which are
originated from the message digest and
the private key
dc's make use of the public key for
authenticating the signature but the
authorization process is much more
complicated when compared with rsa
dsa also provides three benefits which
is the message authentication integrity
verification and non-repardiation
in the image we can see the entire
process of dsf validation
a plain text message is passed on to a
hash function where the digest is
generated which is passed on to a
signing function
signing function also has other
parameters like a global variable g
of random variable k
and the private key of the sender
the outputs are then bundled onto a
single pack with the plain text and sent
to the receiver the two outputs we
receive from the signing functions are
the two 160 bit numbers denoted by s and
r
on the receiver end we pass the plain
text to the same hash function to
regenerate the message digest
it is passed on to verification function
which has other requirements such as the
public key of the sender global variable
g and snr received from the sender
the value generated by the function is
then compared to r
if they match then the verification
process is complete and data integrity
is verified
this was an overview of the way the dsa
algorithm works you already know it
depends on logarithmic functions to
calculate the outputs so let us see how
we can do the same in our next section
we have three phases here the first of
which is key generation to generate the
keys we need some prerequisites
we select a queue which becomes a prime
divisor
we select a prime number p such that p
minus 1 mod q equal to 0
we also select a random integer g which
must satisfy the two formulas being
mentioned on the screen right now
once these values are selected we can go
ahead with generating the keys
the private key can be denoted by x and
it is any random integer that falls
between the bracket of 0 and the value
of q
the public key can be calculated as y
equal to g to the power x mod p
where y stands for the public key
the private key can then be packaged as
a bundle which comprises of values of p
q g and x
similarly the public key can also be
packaged as a bundle having the values
of p
q
g and y
once we are done with key generation we
can start verifying the signature and
this generation
repeat
once the keys are generated we can start
generating the signature
the message is passed through a hash
function to generate the digest h first
we can choose any random integer k which
falls under the bracket of 0 and q
to calculate the first 160 bit number of
assigning function of r we use the
formula g to the power k mod p into mod
cube
similarly to calculate the value of the
second output that is s we use the
following formula that is shown on the
screen
the signature can then be packaged as a
bundle having r and s
this bundle along with a plain text
message is then passed on to the
receiver
now with the third phase we have to
verify the signature we first calculate
the message i just received in the
bundle by passing it to the same hash
function
we calculate the value of w
u1 and u2 using the formulas shown on
the screen we have to calculate a
verification component which is then to
be compared with the value of r being
sent by the sender
this verification component can be
calculated using the following formula
once calculated this can be compared
with the value of r if the values match
then the signature verification is
successful and the entire process is
complete starting from key generation to
the signature generation all the way up
to the verification of the signature
with so many steps to follow we are
bound to have a few advantages to boot
this and we would be right to think so
dsa is highly robust in the security and
stability aspect when compared to
alternative signature verification
algorithms
we have a few other ciphers that aim to
achieve the simplicity and the
flexibility of dsa but it has been a
tough ask for all the other suits
key generation is much faster when
compared to the rsa algorithm and such
while the actual encryption and
decryption process may falter a little
in comparison a quicker start in the
beginning is well known to optimize a
lot of frameworks
dsa requires less storage space to work
its entire cycle
in contrast its direct correspondent
that is rsa algorithm needs a certain
amount of computational and storage
space to function efficiently this is
not the case with dsl which has been
optimized to work with weaker hardware
and lesser resources
the dsa is patented but nist has made
this pattern available worldwide royalty
free a draft version of the speculation
fips1865
indicates that dsa will no longer be
approved for digital signature
generation but it may be used to verify
signatures generated prior to the
implementation date of that standard the
rsa algorithm can be used for general
data encryption and decryption as well
functioning on a similar public key
cryptography architecture it is seen as
a more complex solution to bolster
security so let's go ahead and see what
the rsa algorithm is supposed to do
the rsa algorithm is a public key
signature algorithm developed by ron
rivest adi shamir and leonard edelman
the paper was first published in 1977
and the algorithm uses logarithmic
functions to keep the working complex
enough to withstand brute force and
streamlined enough to be fast post
deployment
rsa can also encrypt and decrypt general
information to securely exchange data
along with handling digital signature
verification
let us understand how it achieved this
we take our plain text message m we pass
it through a hash function to generate
the digest h which is then encrypted
using the sender's private key
this is appended to the original plain
text message and sent over to the
receiver
once the receiver receives the bundle we
can pass the plain text message to the
same hash function to generate a digest
and the ciphertext can be decrypted
using the public key of the sender the
remaining hashes are compared if the
values match then the data integrity is
verified and the sender is authenticated
apart from digital signatures the main
case of rsa is encryption and decryption
of private information before being
transmitted across communication
challenge
this is where the data encryption comes
into play when using rsa for encryption
and decryption of general data it
reverses the key set usage unlike
signature verification it receives the
receiver's public key to encrypt the
data and uses the receiver's private key
in decrypting the data
thus there is no need to exchange any
keys in this scenario there are two
broad components when it comes to rsa
cryptography one of them is key
generation key generation employs a step
of generating the private and the public
keys that are going to be used for
encrypting and decrypting the data
the second part is the encryption and
decryption functions
these are the ciphers and steps that
need to be run when scrambling the data
or recovering the data from the
ciphertext
you will now understand each of these
steps in a next subtopic
keeping the previous two concepts in
mind let us go ahead and see how the
entire process works starting from
creating the keeper to encrypting and
decrypting the information
you need to generate the public and
private keys before running the
functions to generate ciphertext and
plain text to use certain variables and
parameters all of which are explained
we first used two large prime numbers
which can be denoted by p and q
we can compute the value of n as n equal
to p into q and compute the value of z
as p minus 1 into q minus 1.
a number e is chosen at random
satisfying the following conditions and
a number d is also selected at random
following the formula e d mod j equal to
1 and it can be calculated with the
formula given below
the public key is then packaged as a
bundle with n and e and the private key
is packaged as a bundle using n and d
this sums up the key generation process
for the encryption and decryption
function we use the formula c
and m
the ciphertext can be calculated as c
equal to m to the power e mod n and the
plain text can be calculated from the
cipher text as c power d mod n when it
comes to a data encryption example
let's take p and q as 7 and 13.
the value of n can be calculated as 91.
if we select the value of e to be 5 it
satisfy all the criteria that we needed
to
the value of d can be calculated using
the following function which gives it as
29 the public key can then be packaged
as 91 comma 5 and the private key can
then be packaged as 91 comma 29.
the plain text if it is 10 which is
denoted by m
ciphertext can be calculated to the
formula c equal to m to the power e mod
n which gives us 82
if somebody receives this cipher text
they can calculate the plain text using
the formula c to the part d mod n which
gives us the value of 10 as selected as
our plain text
we can now look at the factors that make
the rsa algorithm stand out versus its
competitors in the advantageous topics
of this lesson
rsa encryption depends on using the
receiver's public key so that you don't
have to share any secret key to receive
the messages from others
this was the most glaring flaw faced by
symmetric algorithms which were
eventually fixed by asymmetric
cryptography structure
since the key pairs are related to each
other a receiver cannot intercept the
message since they didn't have the
correct private keys to decrypt the
information
if a public key can decrypt the
information the sender cannot refuse
signing it with his private key without
admitting the private key is not in fact
private anymore
the encryption process is faster than
that of the dsa algorithm
even if the key generation is slower in
rsa many systems across the world tend
to reuse the same keys so that they can
spend less time in key generation and
more time on actual cipher text
management
data will be tamper proof in transit
since meddling with the data will alter
the usage of the keys the private key
won't be able to decrypt the information
hence alerting the receiver of any kind
of manipulation in between
the receiver must be aware of any third
party who possesses the private key
since they can alter the data mid
transit the cases of which are rather
low md5 algorithm was one of the first
hashing algorithms to take the global
stage as a successor to the md4
despite the security vulnerabilities
encountered in the future md5 still
remains a crucial part of data
infrastructure in a multitude of
environments
the md5 hashing algorithm is a one-way
cryptographic functions that accepts a
message of any length as input and it
returns as output a fixed length digest
value to be used for authenticating the
original messages
the digest size is always 128 bits
irrespective of the input
the md5 hash function was originally
designed for use as a secure
cryptographic hash algorithm to
authenticate digital signatures md5 has
also been depreciated for uses other
than as a non-cryptographic checksum to
verify data integrity and detect
unintentional data corruption
ronald rivest founder of rsa data
security and institute professor at mit
designed md5 as an improvement to a
prior message digest algorithm which was
the md4
as already iterated before the process
is straightforward we pass a plain text
message to the md5 hash functions which
in turn performs certain mathematical
operations on the clear text to scramble
the data
the 128-bit digest received from this is
going to be radically different from the
plain text
the goal of any message digest function
is to produce digests that appear to be
random
to be considered cryptographically
secure the hash functions should meet
two requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attacker to generate a message that
matches a specific hash value and second
that it is impossible for an attacker to
create two messages that produce the
same hash value
even a slight change in the plain text
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digest
this goes a long way in preventing hash
collisions which take place when two
different plaintexts have the same
digest
to achieve this level of intricacy there
are a number of steps to be followed
before we receive the digest let us take
a look at the detailed procedure as to
how the md5 hash algorithm works
the first step is to make the plain text
compatible with the hash function
to do this we need to pad the bits in
the message
when we receive the input string we have
to make sure the size is 64 bit short of
a multiple of 512.
when it comes to padding the bits we
must add one first followed by zeroes to
round out the extra characters
this prepares the string to have a
length of just 64 bits less than any
multiple of 512.
here on out we can proceed on to the
next step where we have to pad the
length bits
initially in the first step we appended
the message in such a way that the total
length of the bits in the message was 64
bit short of any multiple of 512.
now we add the length bits in such a way
that the total number of bits in the
message is perfectly a multiple of 512.
that means 64-bit lengths to be precise
are added to the message
our final string to be hashed is now a
definite multiple of 512
the next step would be to initialize the
message digest buffer
the entire hashing plain text is now
broken down into 512-bit blocks there
are four buffers or registers that are
of 32 bits each named a b c and d
these are the four words that are going
to store the values of each of these sub
blocks
the first iteration to follow these
registers will have fixed hexadecimal
values as shown on the screen below
once these values are initial
of these 512 blocks we can divide each
of them into 16 further sub blocks of 32
bits each
for each of these sub blocks we run four
rounds of operations having the four
buffer variables a b c and d
these rounds require the other constant
variables as well which differ with each
round of operation
the constant values are stored in a
random array of 64 elements
since each 32-bit sub-block is run 4
times 16 such sub-blocks equal 64
constant values needed for a single
block iteration
the sub blocks can be denoted by the
alphabet m and the constant values are
denoted by the alphabet t
coming to the actual round of operation
we see our four buffers which already
have pre-initialized values for the
first iteration
at the very beginning the values of
buffers b c and d are passed on to a
non-linear logarithmic function
the formula behind this function changes
by the particular round being worked on
as we shall see later in this video
once the output is calculated it is
added to the raw value stored in buffer
a
the output of this addition is added to
the particular 32-bit sub-block using
which we are running the four operations
the output of this requisite function
then needs to be added to a constant
value derived from the constant array k
since we have
four different elements in the array
repeat since we have 64 different
elements in the array we can use a
distinct element for each iteration of a
particular block
the next step involves a circular shift
that increases the complexity of the
hash algorithm and is necessary to
create a unique digest for each
individual input
the output generated is later added to
the value stored in the buffer b
the final output is now stored in the
second buffer of b of the output
register
individual values of c d and a are
derived from the preceding element
before the iteration started meaning the
value of b gets stored in c
value of c gets stored in d and the
value of d in a
now that we have a full register ready
for this sub block the values of abcd
are moved on as input to the next
sub-block
once all 16 sub-blocks are completed the
final register value is saved and the
next 512-bit block begins
at the end of all these blocks we get a
final digest of the md5 algorithm
regarding the non-linear process
mentioned in the first step the formula
changes for each round it's being run on
this is done to maintain the
computational complexity of the
algorithm and to increase randomness of
the procedure
the formula for each of the four rounds
uses the same parameters that is b c and
d to generate a single output the
formulas being used are shown on the
screen right now
algorithm
unlike the latest hash algorithm
families a 32-bit digest is relatively
easier to compare when verifying the
digest
they don't consume a noticeable amount
of disk storage and are comparatively
easier to remember and reiterate
passwords need not be stored in plain
text format making them accessible for
hackers and malicious actors
when using digest the database security
also gets a boost since the size of all
the hash values will be the same
in the event of a hack or a breach the
malicious actor will only receive the
hashed values so there is no way to
regenerate the plain text which should
be the user passwords in this case
since the functions are irreversible by
design hashing has become a compulsion
when storing user credentials on the
server nowadays
a relatively low memory footprint is
necessary when it comes to integrating
multiple services into the same
framework without a cpu overhead
the digest size is the same and the same
steps are run to get the hash value
irrespective of the size of the input
string
this helps in creating a low requirement
for computational power and is much
easier to run on older hardware which is
pretty common in server farms around the
world
we can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
transit
once the hashes match file integrity
checks are valid and we can avoid data
corruption
hash functions will always give the same
output for the similar input
irrespective of the iteration parameters
it also helps in ensuring that the data
hasn't been tampered with on route to
the receiver of the message
we use our wi-fi every day for work and
we use the internet for entertainment
and communication
the dependency on technology is at an
all-time high thanks to the radical
developments and innovation in these
last two decades
a big portion of this belongs to
ensuring secure channels of
communication and data transmission
the secure hash algorithm are a family
of cryptographic hash functions that are
published by the national institute of
standards and technology along with the
nsa
it was passed as a federal information
processing standard also known as fips
it has four different families of hash
functions ssj 0 is a 160 bit hash
function published in 1993 and it was
closed down later after an undisclosed
significant flaw
sha1 is also a 160 bit hash function
which resembles the earlier md5
algorithm
this was designed by the nsa to be a
part of the digital signature algorithm
sga 2 is a family of two similar hash
functions with different block sizes
known as the sha-256 and the sha-512
they differ in the word size she-256
uses 32-bit words while sha-512 uses
64-bit words
ssh3 is a hash function properly known
as kcac it was chosen in 2012 after a
public competition among non-nsa
designers
it supports the same hash lengths as
hsj2 and its internal structure differs
significantly from the rest of the sha
family
as we have already iterated the process
is straightforward we pass a plain text
message to the sha hash function which
in turn performs certain mathematical
operations on the clear text to scramble
the data
the 160 bit digest received from this is
going to be radically different from the
plain text
the goal of any hash function is to
produce digests that appear to be random
to be considered cryptographically
secure the hash function should meet two
requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attacker to generate a message that
matches a specific hash value
and second it should be impossible for
an attacker to create two messages
producing the exactly same hash value
even a slight change in the plaintext
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digest
this goes a long way in preventing hash
collisions which takes place when two
different plain texts have the same
digest
the sha family functions have some
characteristics that they need to follow
while generating the digest
let's go through a few of them
the length of the clear text should be
less than 2 to the power 64 bits in the
case of sha-1 and sh-256
this is essential to keep the plain text
compatible with the hash function and
the size needs to be in comparison area
to keep the digest as random as possible
the length of the hash digest should be
256 bits in the sha-256 algorithm 512
bits in the sha-512 algorithm and so on
bigger digest usually suggests
significantly more calculations at the
cost of speed and space
we typically go for the longest digest
to bolster security but there must be a
definite balance between the speed and
security of a hash function
by design all hash function of the sha
512 she 256 are irreversible
you should neither get a plain text when
you have the digest beforehand
nor should the digest provide the
original value when you pass it through
the same hash function again
another case of protection is that when
the hash digest is passed into the sha
function for a second time we should get
a completely different digest from the
first instance
this is done to reduce the chance of
brute force attacks
to achieve this level of intricacy there
are a number of steps to be followed
before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the sha algorithm
works
the first step is to make the plain text
compatible with the hash function
to do this we need to pad the bits in
the message
when you receive the input string you
have to make sure the size is 64 bit
shot of a multiple of 512.
when it comes to padding the bits you
must add one first followed by the
remaining zeros to round out the extra
characters
this prepares a string to have a length
just 64 bits less than any multiple of
512
here on out we can proceed to the next
step where we have to pad the length
bits
initially in the first step we appended
the message in such a way that the total
number of bits in the message was 64 bit
short from becoming a multiple of 512.
now we add the length of bits in such a
way that the total number of bits in the
message is a perfect multiple of 512
that means 64 bits plus the length of
the original message becomes a multiple
of 512
this becomes a final string that needs
to be hashed
in the next step we have to initialize
this chaining variables
the entire plain text message can now be
broken down into blocks of 512 bits each
unlike other hash algorithms like md5
which use 4 registers or buffers
sha family use 5 buffers of 32 bits each
they are named a b c d and e these
registers go through multiple rounds of
operation but the first iteration has
fixed hexadecimal values as can be seen
in the screen
moving on we have to process each of the
512-bit blocks by breaking each of them
into 16 sub-blocks of 32 bits each
each of them goes through 4 rounds of
operation that use the entire register
and have the 512-bit block along with a
constant array out of those four rounds
each round has 20 iterations so in
general we have 80 rounds sum total
the constant value of k is an array of
80 elements
of those 80 16 elements are being used
each round so that comes out to 80
rounds for each of those elements
the value of t differs by the number of
rounds as can be seen in the table below
a single formula is necessary to
calculate the output of each round and
iteration
the formula can be a b c d e register is
equal to e plus a non-linear process b
along with a circular shift of a plus wt
plus kt
in this formula abcd is the register
value of the chaining variables as we
discussed before
p is the logical process which has a
different formula for each round
s5 is a circular shift by 5 bits
and wt is a 32-bit string derived from
the existing sub-block this can be
calculated depending on the iteration at
hand
in kt signifies a single element of the
80 character element array which changes
depending on the particular round at
hand
for the values of wt the first 16 values
are the same as that of the sub blocks
so there is no extra calculation needed
for the next 64 elements the value of wt
can be calculated as shown in the
formula here
to better understand this let's take a
look at how each of this goes in a
sequential process we have our initial
register using the 5 words of 32 bits
each in the first step we put the values
of a b c and d to the subsequent
register as the output
next we use a non-linear process p that
changes depending on the round and uses
the values of b c and d as input
whatever output is generated from the
non-linear process it is added with the
value of the e-register
next the value of a is circular shifted
by 5 bits and is added with the output
generated in the previous step
the next step is adding the value of wt
and the constant element of kt the
current output is then stored in the
register a similarly this iteration is
repeated every round and for each
sub-block in the process once all the
registers are complete and all the
sub-blocks are joined together to form
the single ciphertext message we will
have our hashed output regarding the
non-linear process p that uses the
values of b c and d as input
the formula changes every round to
maintain a complexity of the program
that can withstand brute force attacks
depending on the round the values are
passed through a logical operation which
is then added with the values of wt kt
and so on
now that we understand how to get our
hash digest from the plain text let us
learn about the advantages we obtain
when using the sha hash algorithm
instead of relying on data in a plain
text format
digital signatures follow asymmetric
encryption methodology to verify the
authenticity of a document or a file
hash algorithms like ssh 256 and the
industry standard sha 512 go a long way
in ensuring the verification of
signatures
passwords need not be stored in a plain
text format which makes them accessible
to hackers and other malicious actors
when using digest the database security
also gets a boost since the size of all
hash values will be the same
in the event of a hack or a breach the
malicious actor will only receive the
hash values with no way to regenerate
the plain text
in this case the plain text would be
user credentials
since the hash functions are
irreversible by design it has become a
compulsion when storing passwords on the
servers
the ssl handshake is a crucial segment
of the web browsing sessions and it's
done using sha functions
it consists of your web browsers and the
web servers agreeing on encryption keys
and hashing authentication to prepare a
secure connection
it relies on a combination of symmetric
and asymmetric algorithms which ensure
the confidentiality of the data
transmitted between a web server and a
web client like the browsers
you can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
transit
once the hashes match file integrity
checks are valid and data corruption is
avoided
hash functions will always give the same
output for the same input irrespective
of the iteration parameters
it also helps in ensuring that the data
hasn't been tampered with on route to
the receiver of the message with every
passing year a dependence on digital
technology increases stanford we book
transport via mobiles and shop clothes
on our laptops among all these
nitty-gritty day-to-day activities
information such as payment
authentication personal data and private
credentials are transported over the
internet with various website partners
with this reliance on the internet as
gradual
its impact has been every bit as
definite
this statistic represents the daily time
spent online by internet users worldwide
starting from 2011 all the way up to
2021 sorted by device
according to zenith optimedia
in 2018 the average daily minutes of
desktop internet consumption per capita
amounted to 39 minutes and it is slowly
projected to decline until 2020.
however the daily mobile internet
consumption is set to increase to 155
minutes in 2021
if our current lifestyle is any
indication of the future these
statistics are just a window into what
is going to be a future full of
artificial intelligence and its
derivatives
as observed by researchers around the
world this level of dependability has
made us vulnerable to the worst of the
internet
according to the forbes magazine in 2019
the cumulative damage and costs of cyber
effect are far more significant than
those inflicted by natural disasters in
a year
every 11 seconds a business falls victim
to a ransomware attack
the average cost of a data breach in
2020 is 3.86 million dollars
the huge increase in cyber crimes is a
major contributor to the 12 percent
annual growth rate of cyber security
spending
the united states has the world's
highest average data breach crossed at
6.84 million dollars as per 2020 records
opportunities breed innovation and this
has been observed in the cybersecurity
domain as well
to safeguard against such threats the
ssl protocol was developed
let us learn about the ssl protocol
first
ssl or secure sockets layer is an
encryption based internet security
protocol
it was first developed by netscape in
1995 for the purpose of ensuring privacy
authentication and data integrity in
internet communication
ssl is the predecessor to the modern tls
encryption news today
attacks is a cryptographic layer
protocol that provides privacy and
security to communication between a
client and a web server
a website that implements ssl
authentication has https in its url
instead of http
in order to provide a high degree of
privacy ssl encrypts data that is
transmitted across the web this means
that anyone who tries to intercept this
data will only see a garbled mix of
characters that is nearly impossible to
decrypt
ssl initiates an authentication process
called a handshake between two
communicating devices to ensure that
both of them are really who they claim
to be
ssl also digitally signs data in order
to provide data integrity
the internet we use today follows an osi
model or even systems interconnections
model it is a priority system that
characterizes and standardizes the
communication on the internet among its
multiple layers the ssl layer functions
between the application layer and the
transport layer
the application layer provides services
for an application to ensure that
effective communication with another
applic program is possible
the transport layer is responsible for
error-free end-to-end delivery of data
from the source host to the destination
host
since the ssl protocol functions in
between these two layers the data is
encrypted and is authenticated after
being passed through the application and
before it is transmitted over the
network to further understand this
priority table let us look at the table
of how it works
hypertext transfer protocol http is an
application layer protocol that is used
for transmitting information between
computers on the world wide web
http is based on a request response
standard between a client and server
once the data is ready to be shared we
can pass it on to the ssl layers
as you can notice the protocol being
used right now is http
it signifies that the data is
unencrypted and hence vulnerable to
malicious attacks
the data is then passed on to the ssl
where we have the record protocol for
the confidentiality protection and the
handshake protocol for the
authentication of client and server the
sub protocols of the ssl will be later
discussed in detail
after the data is encrypted and ready to
be transmitted it is moved on to the
transport layer where we use the tcp
packets to send their data along to the
internet layer and from that point
forward the data can move to its
destination using the internet protocol
or ip addressing tables
with so many sub protocols and sub
of the ssl protocol the work is divided
into multiple layers and aspects
let's have a look at some of the ways
the ssl layer make the internet safe and
secure
for server authentication the client
uses the server's public key to encrypt
the data which is used to complete the
secret key
the server can generate the secret key
only if it can decrypt the information
with the correct private key
for client authentication the server
uses the public key in the client
certificate
if any of the authentication steps fail
the handshake fails and the session
terminate
this exchange of digital certificates
during the ssl handshake is a part of
the authentication process
ssl provides data integrity by
calculating a message digest or a hash
use of ssl does ensure integrity
provided that the cipher spec in your
channel definition uses a hash algorithm
in the ssl record protocol the hash
value is generated for the data to be
transmitted hence providing a necessary
way to verify data corruption
ssl uses a combination of symmetric and
asymmetric encryption to ensure message
privacy
during the ssl handshake the ssl client
and server agree to an encryption
algorithm and a shared secret key is
used for that particular session
all the messages transmitted between the
client and server are then encrypted
using the same algorithm and key that
ensure that the message will remain
private even if it is intercepted
regarding the multiple layers in the ssl
protocol we have many sub protocols that
ensure the three protection aspects of
security let us learn more about these
the ssl record protocol provides two
services to the ssl connection
confidentiality and message integrity
in ssl record protocol the data is
divided into fragments
the fragment comprises of the encrypted
sha code and the md5 code
after the encryption of the data is done
the last ssl header is also appended to
the data
the handshake protocol is used to
establish sessions this protocol allows
the client and server to authenticate
each other by sending a series of
messages
handshake protocol uses four phase
system to complete its cycle
in phase one both the client and server
send hello package to each other
in phase 2 they exchange the
certificates with the correct private
and public keys
in phase 3 they reply to each other with
the encryption algorithms and the secret
keys while in phase 4 the handshake is
completed
for the chain cipher spec protocol we
use a part of the ssl record protocol
unless handshake is completed the ssl
record output will be in a pending state
after handshake the pending state is
converted into a current state
the chain cipher protocol consists of a
single message which is a one byte inlet
and can hold only one value
the ssl alert protocol is used to convey
ssl related alerts to the peer entity
each message in this protocol contains
only two bytes let's see how the ssl
handshake works in a step-by-step format
we have divided the handshake into four
distinct phases
in phase one the client and server get
acquainted with the hello signal message
from each site
the client sends the ssl version cipher
suit and the session id
the server returns an encryption
algorithm which is chosen from the
cipher suit and a compression algorithm
which is sent from the client hello
signal each
this helps in setting up a common
encryption algorithm and a common hash
value to be used throughout the
handshake process
in phase 2
the server sends its authentication
certificate and requests for client
authentication
the server also sends its public
encryption key
and the phrase with the server hello
done message
once the server sends its public key the
client can use it to encrypt its own
private key which will be later used to
encrypt the data being exchanged between
the client and a server
in phase 3
the client sends its authentication
certificate after verifying the server
with the respective certificate
authorities
the client now send a private key which
is encrypted using the server's
previously sent public key
in phase 4 the client sends the status
of the cipher functions along with a
finished message to end the handshake
from its side
the server also sends the status of the
cipher algorithm and ends with a
finished signal
the data is now encrypted with a
symmetric key client sent in phase 3.
with the end of phase 4 authentication
is complete and the ssl handshake has
maintained the authenticity of the
entire session between the client and
server
to reiterate the entire process
let's go through each step one more time
the client sends a hello request to the
server
the server responds with its own hello
message and sends the server
authentication certificate for
verification
at this point the server's hello signal
is complete
the client exchanges a secret key with
the server to encrypt the data and the
cipher spec parameters are changed
accordingly
the client has now finished its own
handshake activities
the server uses the secret key provided
by the client to encrypt the data and
alters its own cipher spec parameters as
a final step before it sends a finished
signal
at this point the ssl handshake is
complete with an encryption algorithm
and a secure data channel to transmit
information
with ssl protocol being developed in the
early 90s it was bound to be a little
underpowered when pitted against the
current day computers and hackers let's
see its future implications and
replacements
ssl encryption has been depreciated now
with its version 2 and version 3 being
docked by the internet engineering task
force in 2011 and 2015 respectively
there had been far too many security
vulnerabilities to carry on official
activities during the ssl prayer
to further enhance the security the
transport layer security or tls
has been developed as a successor to the
ssl protocol
tls is a proposed ietf standard first
developed in 1999 and the current
version is tls 1.3 which was defined in
august 2018. even though a major part of
the internet is still using tls 1.2 as a
safety net the transition to the latest
version should be completed before any
security deficiencies are exploited a
significant portion of today's internet
is encrypted using secret encryption
keys and for good reason apart from
bolstering security encrypting
communication channels maintain both the
confidentiality and the integrity of the
data being transmitted
the exchange of these secret keys had
always been an arduous task irrespective
of the scope of operation
since the globally standardized
symmetric encryption had seen a lot of
application in the iit industry
exchanging the encryption and decryption
key needed a safe approach
to highlight the issue at hand let's
take a look at henry and stella
both our users want to communicate with
each other in a safe and secure manner
while using encrypted messages
to move forward with the system though
the need to have a secret key that can
both encrypt and decrypt the message
being transmitted
the most glaring issue here is the
inability to exchange the specific key
before they start communicating
since they don't have a secure channel
anyone looking at the communication
channel can easily intercept this key
if the key is intercepted all the
messages that are exchanged between
henry and stella can easily be read by
the malicious actors since they already
have the decryption key this is where
the diffie-hellman key exchange
algorithm comes into play
it made the process much more
streamlined and more secure
let's start by learning a bit more about
this exchange process
diffie-hellman algorithm is a method for
securely exchanging cryptography keys
over insecure channels without
compromising the security and integrity
of the data transmission
it was developed and published in 1976
by martin hellman and whitfield defi
the main usp of this algorithm was the
ability to exchange such critical crees
over insecure networks
once the keys are exchanged without any
malicious actors they can be used to
transfer encrypted data and thereby
establish a secure channel for
communication
until we receive the asymmetric
encryption algorithms that never relied
on any category of key exchange
symmetric encryption was the only way to
communicate securely
a secure method to exchange the private
keys for this brand of cryptography was
much needed
a very important part of how the
diffie-hellman exchange works at the
mechanism behind one-way functions where
the output should not be able to be
deduced back to the original input
to better understand how the one-way
functions work let's take a look at this
exchange process using color theory
initially both the users must have a
private color decided on their own and
it should not be made public even to the
user with whom we'll be exchanging keys
let's say the first user has a private
color as red and the second user has the
private color as blue
next they should be having a common
public color which can be decided over
insecure channels if need be
in this case we are choosing this common
color to be yellow in the next step both
users have to mix their private colors
and the publicly decided common color
after mixing you're going to get a new
color mixture with each of the users
once we receive a new mixture for each
user this mixture is then sent to each
other now this is done over an insecure
channel which means this communication
can easily be intercepted by any
malicious actors who are listening on to
the channel
at this point of time even if the
mixtures are exchanged the hackers have
only that the mixtures they do not
possess the private colors of both users
after the mixtures are received
they are supposed to mix their own
private color with the received mixture
of the opposite user once the colors are
mixed they will both get a single color
which will be selected as the final
secret color or it can be a final secret
key
now even though this entire
communication took place over an
insecure channel because of the
inability of the hacker to receive the
private colors of both users he has no
idea that the secret color in the case
of transmission is actually brown and
not green or yellow which he intercepted
during the transmission this is how the
convey functions work and the keys can
be exchanged over insecure channels
without compromising on the privacy now
that we understand the theory and the
root logic behind this exchange
let us learn more about the mathematical
side of the diffie-hellman key exchange
in our next section
we can break down the entire key
exchange process into three distinct
steps
step one is choosing q and alpha
first we choose a prime number queue
which will stay consistent throughout
the process
once we have selected q we need to
select a primitive root of q and denote
it by the symbol alpha
this alpha will be a primitive root
modulo of q if every number co prime to
q is congruent to the power of alpha mod
q
now to satisfy the primitive root
requirement of a prime number the values
of alpha mod q alpha square mod q all
the way up to alpha q minus 1 mod q must
all follow this formula where it should
always be less than q which has the
range of ranging from 1 up to q minus 1.
if this condition is satisfied alpha can
be selected as a primitive root for q
moving on to step 2 we have a driving
the key pair process
let's say for the first user we assumed
the private key to be denoted by xa
where the xa's value should always be
less than q
after we decide on the private key the
public key which will be denoted by y a
can be calculated using the formula
alpha to the power x a mod q
now that we have both the private key
and the public key settle the key pair
of the first user becomes xa and ya
similarly for the second user we let's
say the private key is supposed to be xb
which must also be less than q
the public key of the second user can
also be calculated using the formula
alpha to the power xb mod q
similar to the first user the key pair
will have both the private key and
public key which becomes xb and yb
finally in step 3 we have the key
generation steps
we already have the parameters for the
first user which will be his private key
the receiver's public key and the value
of q which will stay constant
to calculate the secret key or the
secret color as denoted by brown in the
color theory the formula we're going to
use is yb to the power xa mod q
for the second user we're going to use a
similar formula but with slightly
different parameters
it will be the private key of the user
public key of the other user and the
value of q
the formula will be similar in the phase
of y a to the power x b mod q
to satisfy the entire diffie-hellman key
exchange process both these generated k
value must be equal to successfully
generate the key these values should be
equal
the key generated will be used to
encrypt the messages while being
transmitted over insecure channels as
denoted by the brown color
to get a more clear idea of how it is
going to work we can take a real world
example with mathematical values to
prove this theory
in step one we have to choose q and
alpha so let's say if we choose a prime
number q to be 17
in choosing alpha which will be the
primitive root of q we have decided
we're going to take alpha as three now
to satisfy the condition of the
primitive root we can check that three
mod 17 which is three three square more
seventeen nine and all the way up to
three power sixteen mod seventy they all
fall below seventy so it satisfy the
condition to be a primitive root of the
prime number 70.
in step 2 we need to settle on the
private and the public key
for the first user the private key which
will be considered as xa let's say we
decided to be 15. now that we have the
value of the private key settled at 15
we can calculate the public key with the
formula
3 power 15 mod 17 which is supposedly
alpha to the power xa mod q the value
becomes 6
so our key pair becomes 15 and 6 which
is the private key and the public key of
the first user
for the second user let's consider the
private key xb to b13
the public key can then be calculated
this formula 3 to the power 13 mod 17
which has the value of 12.
so in the second user's case the key
pair can be 13 and 12.
in step 3 which is the key generation we
already have the requisite parameters
for both users
to calculate the secret key on the first
user we're going to use the formula of k
equal to 12 power 15 mod 17 which gives
the output as 10.
similarly for second user we're going to
calculate the secret key using the
formula 6 to the power 13 mod 17 which
gives the value as 10.
now that we have both values of k at 10
this becomes our n secret encryption and
decryption key
both users can encrypt the messages with
this value of k before transmitting the
data and the receiver can generate the
key on their site too as seen in this
video
so unless anyone has the secret key as a
supplement to the publicly decided key
no amount of hacking can break the
secure channel
thankfully this key exchange process was
very well received and is being used
nowadays in a lot of places
let's read about some of these occasions
the public key infrastructure or pki is
a set of tools and rules to enforce
public key cryptography with multiple
entities it governs the issuance of
digital certificates around the internet
to maintain data confidentiality
our internet browsers are authenticated
with website servers using an ssl or tls
certificate and many encryption keys in
between this is only possible due to
this diffie-hellman key exchange
algorithm which enables the secure
exchange of cryptographic entities over
all channels
we also have secure shell access or ssh
for short it is a cryptographic protocol
used to access system terminals from a
third party appliance or application
the diffie helmet algorithm helps in
exchanging the keys between both systems
so that remote access can be enabled
here we will focus on the popular
cryptography questions that can be asked
in a cyber security interview our
experienced instructor bipin will take
you through these questions so let's get
started the first question define
cryptography encryption and decryption
now cryptography
is used by security professionals to
scramble data
into non-readable format
which is used in securing that
information
so it involves converting data from a
readable format into a non-readable
format and then reversing it back to
readable format again
for example the word computer is now
scrambled into looking like an
unreadable format now if you look at
this word that it has been scrambled
into it would be very difficult
for a human to figure out
what the actual word was
now in this scenario we have taken an
algorithm where we have made a
shift of the alphabet where we have
added two alphabets the current one so c
plus two becomes e
o plus two becomes q m plus two becomes
o so we have done a shift of two and
thus the key over here for this
algorithm
is the alphabet plus two so any person
who figures that out will be able to
unscramble this and convert this back
into readable text
the fact of scrambling uh readable text
data into something that is unreadable
by using a particular key is what
cryptography is all about
now as we discussed the decryption again
is
replacing the alphabet and taking it
further back by two characters so e
minus two becomes c q minus two becomes
o o minus two becomes m and so on so
forth so anybody who knows this key uh
the shift key
anybody will able to
decrypt this particular character so
this depends on the user if i want to
utilize alphabet plus five then the
spacing the shifting of that character
will be the fifth character from that
particular character
and so on so forth
the next question what is the difference
between ciphertext and cleartext
ciphertext refers to the text which is
encrypted and totally undesirable
the message received after decryption is
known as clear text this text is
comprehensible so the word computer is
clear text that means that it has not
been treated to any cryptographic
measures it does what it is intended to
be
however if the moment we encrypt it that
means we scramble it into unreadable
text by using any of the algorithms that
we'll be looking at
that text is known as a cipher text
and without the key this becomes
unreadable
the clear text as discussed is the plain
word that we have utilized we are using
the english language in this instance so
the plain word computer is the clear
text once we add the encryption layer to
it
we get the cipher text to it
moving on to the next question what is a
block cipher
this refers to the method of encrypting
the plain message block by block the
plain message is broken down into fixed
size blocks and then encrypted now a
block cipher is normally used for data
that is stored so a data that is stored
on a hard disk and we want to encrypt
that data that is known as block
encryption or a block cipher so a block
cipher is an algorithm
that will allow you to encrypt data that
is stored onto a hard disk so in this
example we've got
a plain text which is 64 bits in size
and we have
added a layer of encryption to it so
plain text plus the key that we have
studied in the previous questions and
then the scrambled data out of it which
is unreadable and thus encrypted then
the next question what is public key
infrastructure now the public key
infrastructure is a set of policies
which secures the communication between
a server and a client it uses two
cryptographic keys public and private
so
the infrastructure itself is a set of
policies people procedures and
techniques which are standardized in
nature
and are globally accepted which allow us
to use digital certificates to encrypt
data and decrypt the data
at the other end
we use asymmetric encryption over here
which means that we are used two keys
one is a public key to encrypt and the
private key to decrypt
the other part of the encryption is a
symmetric encryption where the same key
is used to encrypt and the same key is
used to decrypt
now in a public key infrastructure
like i said we have standardized that so
insta in the standardizing part of it
these are the various players that have
been defined in the public key
infrastructure the first is this
user or the sender in this scenario the
one who requires this digital signature
to digitally sign a particular
transaction or a communication a
registration authority with whom they
are going to register for that
particular key the certification
authority who issues that key
the verification of authority who
validates the
key itself and the recipient who is
going to be the other party of that
particular transaction so how is this
utilized
a sender or the user who requires this
digital signature will request or apply
for a digital signature with the
registration authority the registration
authority would validate the
genuinely of the user so they might do
some
identity verification or
proof of residence or something like
that once they've identified the person
and they have validated the information
they will then send the request to the
certification authority stating that the
sender has been validated and we can and
the certification authority can issue
the digital certificate to the
particular user
they will send the public key to the
sender which will be utilized by the
sender for further transactions so when
the sender
is going to sign some data and wants to
send it across to the recipient they
will use the public key to sign it and
send it across
the recipient will then validate with
the verification authority to see if the
data the signed data is correct or not
now
while the certification authority sends
the public key to the sender the
certification authority updates the
private key with the verification
authority so whatever is signed by the
sender uh received by the recipient and
they want to validate it they will send
it back to the verification authority
the verification authority will validate
using the private key once the private
key is validated
it will then send the ok signal back to
the recipient thus allowing the
validation of that particular
transaction
if the signature is tampered with or is
not the very fiction authority is not
able to validate the signature it will
then send a denial message back to the
recipient and the transaction will
not go through
so the pka enables trusted digital
identities for people so the pki grants
secure access to digital resources based
on the infrastructure that has been
created and the core of the pki is a
certification authority which ensures
that the trustworthiness of the digital
data is
ensured
so
going back to the previous slide
these are the key players that have been
standardized in the public key
infrastructure the certification
authority is the authority that issues
the digital certificates the validation
authority is the one who validates that
digital certificate
moving on what is rsa
rsa is one of the first public key
crypto systems that is used for secure
data transmission it stands for reverse
xiaomira and adelman now these are the
three people who have created this
algorithm randy west adishamir and
leonard edelman who are the inventors of
this technique it is a asymmetric
cryptography algorithm which works on
both public and private keys hence the
encryption key is public and the
decryption key is kept private now as we
have discussed earlier symmetric and
asymmetric cryptography symmetric
cryptography is where the same key is
used to encrypt and decrypt whereas
asymmetric cryptography is where there
are two keys to encrypt and decrypt the
algorithm what are the few alternatives
to rsa now rsa is an algorithm that is
used for encryption there are a lot of
other algorithms that can be utilized uh
to alter or to scramble data depending
on your requirements so in the previous
question we have studied and we have
talked about what
rsa is it stands for
reverse xiaomi redundant method three
creators of that particular algorithm
but there are a lot of alternatives to
this algorithm depending on how secure
you want that data to be
and some of them are
listed here on your screen duo security
octa google authenticator and lastpass
lastpass is a password manager
so is duo security google authenticate
is something that we all utilize it is
an application that we can download and
store on our mobile devices and we can
set that up to
authenticate ourselves with certain
portals so it issues a unique id to us
which once
utilized will allow us access to those
particular portals octa is an identity
manager where you have created different
digital identities and you have assigned
them certain permissions and based on
your authentication mechanisms octa will
allow or disallow access to those
different applications or different
portals as you have configured it so all
four
are
authorization authentication mechanisms
which can be used as alternatives to rsa
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
next question what are the prime
objectives of modern cryptography and
this is a very important question
because we've so far looked at what
cryptography is and what public key
infrastructure is but what is the
achievement out of it why are we
utilizing it and what do we want to
gain out of it so the main and the prime
objectives of modern cryptography are
as follows mentioned on your screen the
first one is confidentiality
the second one is non-repudiation
third one is authenticity and the fourth
one is integrity
now if i go back to the first one
confidentiality uh that is where i want
to keep data confidential that means it
will only be visible to the authorized
users right so here i've
created a list of people who have deemed
as authorized users and have created a
digital identity to them and have given
access controls to those people now that
is how confidentiality is
ensured so when we want to keep data
confidential we create a list of users
who we are going to allow access to
certain resources and we are going to
define what access controls are to be
utilized what access are allowed whether
they got an administrative access or
user level access and only those
authorized users are going to be
able to access these resources that is
how we maintain confidentiality
the next one is non-repudiation
non-repetition is the prevention of
denial of having been a part of a
particular transaction so in the public
key infrastructure that we discussed
where a digital signature was utilized
to sign
a particular transaction
and then sent to the recipient the
sender would not be able to deny of
having originated that transaction
because it was using their
digital certificate thus non-reputation
comes into the picture uh one more
example that we can have here is uh on
our mobile phones when we use sms short
messaging service and we send a message
to
uh to another person the person when
they receive a message the number is
validated by the service operator
and thus the sender cannot
deny having sent that message the sender
at the same time can have a delivery
report sent to them
from that the message was delivered to
the inbox of the recipient and thus if
the recipient denies having received
that message the delivery report becomes
proof
of having
that message being delivered to their
inbox thus both the parties cannot deny
of have a of being a part of that
particular transaction
then comes the part of authenticity
now in confidentiality we have created a
digital identity assigned it to a
particular person
and we have given them digital
signatures where they cannot deny having
being a part of that transaction but
authenticity is the part where they try
to prove that they are who they claim to
be so if i am claiming a digital
identity
i have to prove that i am that person
who i'm trying to claim to be and an
example to that is when we go to our
gmail.com websites it first asks us what
is our username our username is normally
our email address which identifies the
account that we are trying to access
right so this account is confidential
because it is only authorized for a
particular person
and once
they identify themselves by identifying
the email address that's when the
authentication part comes into the
picture where it asks for the password
now it has never ever happened that we
just go on to the gmail.com type in a
password and then it figures out which
account we are talking about so the
first step is always the confidentiality
part where we identify which account we
are talking about and then we try to
authenticate as the owner of that
particular account by providing the
appropriate password to that account if
both of these match only then do we get
access to that account and
we are able to make whatever
transactions we want to make now when we
are making those transactions not
reputation comes into the place where
all our activities also being logged so
we have identified our account we have
authenticated ourselves by providing the
password so the proof is there that it
is us who are trying to access it
and then whatever activity we do send an
email receive an email delete something
attach something all of those activities
are logged
and stored as proof of what actions have
been done
so tomorrow if we deny having sent that
email gmail can still prove to us
through those logs that though that that
activity was done by us
and the fourth part is integrity which
ensures that the data received and sent
and
sent by the sender and received by the
recipient has not been modified while in
uh motion
so the integrity part is the
trustworthiness of that data that the
data has not been modified by any hacker
or any other
entity and is still trustworthy
so these are the four prime objectives
of modern cryptography once i have
scrambled that data
using
my public's signature it is only my
private signature that is going to
decrypt it right
using these mechanisms i will be able to
achieve all these four aspects
of cryptography and
security next question what is safer
now safer stands for secure and fast
encryption routine which is also a block
cipher as we have discussed previously
block cipher is a cipher that is used to
encrypt data that is stored
so it has a 64-bit block size and
byte-oriented algorithm cipher's
encryption and decryption procedures are
highly secure this technology is widely
used in applications like digital
payment card so when you're using your
a digital
payment gateway to make transactions so
you have you have gone on to an online
portal you want to purchase a particular
item
and then it takes you to another
payment gateway where you have to fill
in your credit card information
sensitive information like your
expiry dates cvv information
and then the otp or the password that
you have created for your particular
account now all of these need to be
secured or highly secured based on
pcidss which is the payment card
industry data security standard so these
standards ensure that certain protocols
are utilized to attain that level of
security safer is one of those block
ciphers that is used under the digital
payment gateway infrastructure next
question how does the public
infrastructure public key infrastructure
work
now we have already discussed this in
the previous diagrams we have identified
the key players the certification
authority the registration authority the
end user who requires the digital
certificate the validation authority
who's going to validate it and then the
recipe and the end user with whom the
transaction is going to be
conducted so the first point here is
the request for the digital certificate
is sent to the registration authority
they validate it and then they okay to
the certification authority who then
process the request and the digital
certificate is issued to the person who
has requested it
so when the person wants to conduct that
transaction they use that
digital certificate to sign that
transaction with the end user the end
user validates that with the validation
authority and once validated the
transaction goes through and now the
last question what is the blowfish
algorithm
it is a 64-bit symmetric encryption
algorithm so this is an algorithm that
uses the same key
to encrypt and the same key to decrypt
the same secret key is used to encrypt
and decrypt the messages here the
operations are based on exclusive ors
and additions to the on 32-bit words
the key has a maximum length of 448 bits
now this is a little bit technical uh
you might not want to go with this
technical in an interview question you
just need to identify what the algorithm
is used for so whether it is a symmetric
algorithm which means it uses the same
key or
a symmetric algorithm where it uses a
public key to encrypt and a pi private
key to decrypt
this the blowfish algorithm is just one
more algorithm which uses symmetric
encryption to encrypt and decrypt data
algorithms that we have seen rsa and
others that we have discussed as far as
the interview questions are concerned
what we need to remember is
which algorithms are symmetric which
algorithms are asymmetric what do
symmetric algorithms do and what do
unsymmetric uh symmetric algorithms do
and we also look at block ciphers and
stream ciphers block ciphers are
utilized to encrypt data that is stored
stationary data data at rest and stream
ciphers are utilized for data in motion
while they're being streamed so ssl and
tls is another algorithm that comes into
the picture when you're looking at
streaming data with this we reached the
end of our full course on cryptography
we hope you learned a lot of new
concepts today and will be able to make
use of your newly acquired knowledge to
propel your career forward if you have
any questions or queries regarding the
topics explained in this video please
feel free to ask us in the comments
section and we will be happy to assist
you in your learning stay safe and thank
you for watching
you